brian fury
gonna be twilight conflict for this
stage
yep
two characters we haven't yet seen
uh from from these players or on stream
at all so i wanna see how of course this
play out i'm a big eddie fan
uh i feel like he's just
one of those characters like once you
have movement especially if you have the
ability to kind of back that weave in
and out it's it's a it's a sight to see
it's like to be old
and he's definitely back dashing he's
one of those oh yeah he's he understands
how to play this character
he'd make winner's side top 8 for no
reason oh yeah those pants aren't just
for show counter it
nice good conversion here goes for the
down two three
i always expect that to screw in the air
therefore
i mean it should be right
it looks like it yeah
but they did give it uh
in the most recent balance update they
did give it homing properties which it
did not have before you were able to
sidestep it
i mean you could still jab it but i mean
at least it has its homie now you can
jab it no way
yeah you can you can easily float him
out of it in the in the opening frames
of that of that attack
right now though callum what the lead
he traded right there
uh-huh nice slow jab follow up here
oh you went for it
catch it do it again
oh boy is it gonna work
it did definitely is that's crazy
with that wally behind eddie you never
know where he's gonna go but look at
that perfect there survives with just
the pixel callum
first two rounds because of it
what was to throw get off me
hatchet down to follow up this time
the challenge man cal looking
comfortable right now
change the misery let's go
oh no
that might be the entire game actually
wall carry here
does it not alive he's alive
oh my gosh into the mid
good stuff man that was very impressive
very dominant
uh and able to kind of close it out of
the end there so first match in the
books already
yeah calum looked really comfortable in
that one right and he wasn't really faze
you know like double hatches like that's
fine i have a good life lead uh you saw
the back dash canceled they're very
clean from calum uh you know he's an
eddie player and he if you put him on
the infinite stage i feel like you know
he's gonna just run away forever so i'm
out i'm out of here
he's looking like a strong container to
take the whole thing right now we'll see
uh
big daddy mike has an answer for him uh
but yeah something i saw like you know
he went to relax and big daddy microwave
for the down back too like does brian
have a better option to pick up relax
and get a better punish off it
it depends especially on what you want
to do so obviously if he transitioned
into another move right away that down
back to would have picked up but because
he just stayed neutral it did not um
there's moves like down three two which
would have splattered him into the wall
but i could have put him in some hot
okie so it really depends on what you
want to do i see but down back 2 is
generally the best option if you know
they're going to do something afterwards
gotcha
so right now calum
big chill and it's what it looks like
you know that the throw the throw breaks
have been good for them the movement has
been great from him uh obviously his
offense and defense have been on point
so far you know not really a lot of
holes in this game but i'm not really
sure what big daddy might have to change
to really make things work out for him
the match up specifically with brian and
eddie i mean obviously you and eddie
made yourself mark you know like what do
you feel about it like is that always
been like a problem matching for brian
or is like eddie comfortable there
um i i really think it depends so uh he
looked comfortable because his ability
to kind of get weave in and out of the
action so he definitely looked
comfortable there but brian
any any of the characters that have
really fast attacks that can really kind
of close out things and force eddie to
put in risk to kind of beat out i'd like
to see uh big daddy maybe go for some
back ones and some jabs because you know
eddie doesn't have a sidestep he doesn't
have a strong sidestep i should say one
that he can rely on consistently so i
think uh using things that can kind of
help space out in the matchup maybe like
three plus four back one that will help
go a long way
gotcha wow great low prairie here to
start off all right maybe uh better
defensive options could help too
oh yeah go for the taunt
was just the threat empty threat i don't
know
i don't know we'll see i mean
oh oh he had the knight stuck there down
back two down by two is a great move as
well
the only thing is you got to be careful
because eddie does have some great
counter hit tools in the open
and it does have the thread of the
really really fast while setting one
but of course it's high so let's let's
see if he's able to pull something out
here again with the 12 frame back three
as well if you could counter hit confirm
oh no there's that while setting one
this is gonna hurt big time relax two
four three the follow up here
what's the
mix hatchet kick oh i like the downward
one oh my gosh
greedy greedy and look at that first
round to calum again
that was
a big mistake like he had the life lead
right and time was winding down he had
the pressure he just gave him a low
uh and callum took it
[Music]
out man huge lead yeah there's no need
to put yourself into risk here so that
back dash is very smart here using that
standing four very fast mid attack
causing problems here big daddy mike
he needs this round otherwise it's all
over and callum's gonna move on to our
winners finals
five rounds straight callum running away
with it right now
mix
oh no punish he could have went for the
big launch there the jet upper would
have been the right move
nice good down back to the follow up
here let's see what he does
oh that could have been a launch
got to be careful
again the back dash you got the lead
don't take huge wrists here orbit yeah
oh
you just said it too don't take big
races like how about a low poke you
won't kill him but what's the worst that
could happen yeah you got to be careful
into the drive
again out of range there oh it's over
northern cross
yeah he just instantly dug full crash
attack there very nice
i mean it's a great move it's only jab
punishable i i would go for it more
[Music]
nice back one again another one another
one oh my gosh
if eddie does block that though he's
gonna get along so he's gonna have to be
very careful at how he places those
hatching kicks
[Music]
all right big daddy mike's turning
things around can he stay on the
winner's side of the bracket right now
oh it doesn't matter
there's blood on the dance floor oh here
we go the follow up
i hate that new move i want to duck it
every time
yeah it looks like it's duckable too
because of the slight delay like oh let
me duck
damn double vertical orbital the taunt
dash is to stay up with them that's so
cool actually
oh nice japanese into oh this is huge
life follow up here
okay yo what are you doing
you gotta make sure the top hits oh it's
not gonna be enough
it is enough it is enough
wow that's impressive
big daddy mike this is why you call me
big daddy tying it up
[Music]
and calum right now
i i don't know that that he he was in
the lead right going into this
like he was in control then he started
taking those risks those risks started
coming out and then you know he just
capitalized so big daddy making it work
bringing us to a pivotal game three now
you're like don't take any risk right
this how about a low kick boom orbital
did not need that that was very very
impressive by big daddy mike they're
very nicely done mozambique the only
representative from mozambique in this
top eight right now uh and staying alive
on the side of the bracket ties it up
one apiece impressive comeback there uh
man i really don't know uh what to say
about because you know callium callum
really looked like he he was in control
right he looked like he was running away
with it everything was going his way uh
big daddy mike wasn't punishing
correctly on some things you know it
really would be difficult and also
second game they went to infinite stage
so i thought really callum's gonna just
run away all day uh instead it turns out
that big daddy mike just turned things
around a lot of hatches right lots and
lots of hatchet kicks as you mentioned
eddie can launch it but uh he actually
hasn't launched one correctly right he
did that one where the watson one is
late but then the second lost him anyway
uh who knows man
but here we go either way three
this is gonna be the big one very
important another open stage
infinite azure
pressure's on now though
guaranteed top three finish whoever wins
this game
here we go i have a feeling he's gonna
back out of there oh he went with the
down four two to start it off running
slash kick there it's another great move
that kind of restricts and catches up
towards where eddie's at as well nice
low job
no he doesn't get the float
second hit nice goes for the downford
four
and again see i feel like it's kind of
forcing callum to actually start using
more of these tools more of these low
attacks which is going to put them into
a bigger risk later on
fisherman slam could have happened there
did not connect
and big daddy's doing such a good job
like he's got the likely here you can
tell calm's like much more nervous and
approaching oh my gosh
not looking good but here's the
follow-up there guaranteed now that four
chord four
got the weight spent as well big daddy
looking good here just doesn't have to
take a big risk don't go low is what i'm
saying
running out of time
nice block
back one didn't need that but hey it
worked out
first round of big daddy mike who now
has the lead here in the match
hatchet
oh
big daddy looking really good now it
looks like he's in control now in
complete control which is a big
what a punish that was crazy nice whip
punish
yeah that's something we haven't really
seen out of calum yet right
yeah then down four three plus four
excellent range on that very fast too
it's 15 frames so
did get the buff over uh second legacy
time
that's huge yeah it used to be 17. yeah
dude what the heck
oh boy
wait the 15 really try it again
do it again
is it follow up here
his legs are gone as far as i'm coming
there it is
blue stuff back at him do it do it now
uh-huh time
oh
[Applause]
that hurt that one oh my gosh i don't
think that's what you want i think he
wanted the four forward four he got
forward four instead
here we go right now big daddy mike on
the verge there's the punish we've been
waiting for it
the follow up here two four three i just
realized the damage i got five rounds
straight now big daddy mike's five
rounds straight
uh-huh
see what he does here
oh outer head big daddy mike this could
oh my gosh he dropped it
you got to be able to clean your plate
finish your food
he's got a back dash do not take a huge
risk do not get oh my god
he's running he goes out the round
seriously oh my god he's all caught up
the drive is gonna hit for calum he's
not out of it yet right when he forward
dashed he ate the blue stuff so right
now
callum staying alive nice step there man
he knows
eddie's down for two does not have
amazing tracking at all but that's when
he got it mixed up there's a ford four
there we go
ouch
nice stuff
follow up here back three three into the
follow-up combo unscaled on the last hit
oh he almost he could have launched
there
rage mode
you know he's gonna do that blue back
one it's coming
here final final round callum versus big
daddy mike south africa versus
mozambique to make it into top three
you gotta be beautiful
it's not going to do too much damage
though
has a chance here let's see what he does
yo now big daddy's desperate he's going
for these lows
but he's got to be aware almost every
single low that he can do he's going to
get launched punished by that while
standing 1-3
30 seconds left
oh he's cute
it's gonna it's he's not gonna be
enraged he's not gonna be rage let's see
what he does now he's in right i mean
the rage
and he's still living
oh my god
oh my gosh that's crazy
that was so much damage so fast you
thought it wasn't going to knock me rage
but it did and that damage afterward for
each of those hits increased because of
it
wow
that was so unfortunate for calum but it
will be big daddy mike moving on to the
top three